bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat à suivre ce matin sur notre
antenne l'audition de brice hortefeux
ministre de l'intérieur par les
sénateurs de la mission d'information
sur les conséquences de la tempête
xynthia
une audition qui intervient alors que
les sénateurs ont déjà rendu un premier
rapport d'étape dans lequel il préconise
de clarifier la cartographie et
notamment cette fameuse expression de
zones noires expression inappropriée
selon ils préfèrent en effet parler de
zones d'acquisition à l'amiable
autre recommandation des sénateurs
modifier la législation pour mieux
prévenir les risques et puis pour à
terme mieux protégés à les citoyens
bonne matinée à tous sur public sénat
monsieur le ministre je voudrais vous
remercier de venir à notre invitation
pour vous auditionné puisque il ya de
nombreuses problématiques qui sont du
ressort de la compétence de votre
périmètre ministériel
et nous vous remercions infiniment de
tête parmi nous pour répondre à un
certain nombre de questions qu'on se
pose le président de république
lorsqu'il est venu en en vendée très
vite après la tempête avait indiqué
d'ailleurs que le résultat et le drame
d'un tiers et est bien sûr liée à des
événements climatiques exceptionnels
d'ailleurs à une coïncidence absolument
exceptionnel mais pas seulement il y
avait eu un certain nombre de décisions
de fait qui avait amené l'ampleur de ce
drame
donc on a fait nombreuses auditions pour
ce qui concerne cette audition la ce qui
nous intéresse c'est plusieurs pans
d'abord le sujet de la prévision le
sujet de l'urbanisme le sujet de la
prévention
donc nous sommes très impatients de vous
entendre sur sur ces sujets je vais vous
donner la parole peut être pour une pour
une déclaration et puis ensuite on
pourra préciser si vous voulez bien tel
tel ou tel point merci monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur
naturellement
ce qui à ce dont on se souviendra dans
cette séquence particulièrement
douloureux c'est qu'il ya eu 53 victimes
c'est un bilan qui est extrêmement lourd
et ça signifie que s'il est lourd il est
inacceptable et nous devons d'athus a
engagé cette réflexion et je vous
remercie d'avoir pris cette initiative
parce que des événements climatiques
difficiles grave se reproduiront
inéluctablement
il faut nous organiser tirer les leçons
de ce que nous avons vécu pour que
précisément à l'avenir et les
conséquences que nous déplorons
aujourd'hui ne se reproduise pas ça
signifie qu'on doit faire émerger une
culture partagée du risque alors qu'il
ya trois points concernant le mystère
dont j'ai la responsabilité
et effectivement la sécurité civile il
ya le soutien aux collectivités
territoriales et plus particulièrement
son soutien financier exceptionnel dont
j'ai souhaité le déclenchement et puis
il ya le contrôle de légalité c'est à
dire en clair ce que j'attendais
représentant de l'état dans ce domaine
ce sont les trois thèmes qui me semblent
répondra à vos interrogations
alors sur la chaîne de sécurité civile
je crois qu'elle a été efficace
en effet grâce à une bonne anticipation
le vraiment où les secours nécessaires
étaient déployés à temps sur les autres
sinistrés et des injures et des
dépressions l'aurait rendu hommage
c'était le 25 mars dans la cour de
l'hôtel de beauvau parce que je trouvais
que c'était particulièrement mérité
alors il y avait des mesures
préparatoires qui a été prise en amont
de la catastrophe dell annonce a été
très concrètement du passage en
vigilance rouge par météo france
je les détails pas gérable simplement
pour mémoire il y avait l'activation du
centre opérationnel de gestion
interministérielle des crises il ya une
audioconférence immédiate à violetta le
cogic c'était il ya 30 personnes quand
même
et l'audioconférence immédiate avec les
services de l'état c'est à dire les
zones de défense concernés météo france
et l'institut et les grands opérateurs
des réseaux la mise en alerte des
préfectures et des déesses 10 et la pré
positionnement des mains la sécurité
civile c'est à dire qu'il est en fait
concrètement un mouvement de 3 130
sapeurs sauveteurs vers poitiers
angoulême dès l'après-midi du 27 la mise
en alerte de huit hélicoptères et
l'envoyant à l'envoi de moyens de
pompage lourd date signifie très
concrètement que quand on est en
toujours dans cette phase bilan dès le
dimanche 28 tous les moyens nécessaires
étaient engagés sur des sites impactés
pour les moyens image un pcet concernés
1800 personnes de la sécurité civile
1250 sapeurs-pompiers 450 militaires 50
3 personnel de l'établissement de
d'établissement de soutien opérationnel
et logistique pour les moyens aériens
c'était donc huit hélicoptères qui ont
affecté 81 12 heures de vol et ans couru
90 victimes dont la moitié ce qui est
important au cours de la nuit grâce à
des systèmes de jumelles à vision
nocturne
ça a permis ce maillage territorial ça a
permis d'intervenir dans les 30 minutes
délai était trop et pour les moyens de
pompage et 60 pompes d'une capacité
d'épuisement de 26 mille mètres cubes
heures c'est alliant été très
concrètement l'intégralité et des moyens
de pompage lourds de la réserve
nationale qui ont été déployés sur ces
zones sinistrées alors la coordination
des moyens aériens voyage ou simplement
est véritablement a connu quelques
difficultés dans un premier temps ces
difficultés ont été rapidement résolus
et ses difficultés ont d'ores et déjà
été prises en compte dans le schéma de
réponse aux prochaines crises nature on
a tiré certaines leçons ce qui s'est
passé très concrètement pour hd
difficulté simplement parce que la
multiplication des hélitreuillages
dès 6 heures du matin le dimanche 28
février n'a pas été accompagné une
coordination entre
les deux départements et c'était
d'autant plus pourtant indispensable
coordination qui relève comme vous savez
de deux zones de défense distincts il
fallut en fait à temps en gros le milieu
de la matinée tient que quelques heures
mais pas pas très longue
et pour que soit réalisé 1 re
déploiement des moyens aériens et qui a
permis d'assurer effectivement à ce
moment là les opérations ce qu au profit
des deux départements
il faudra aussi remédier à ces
difficultés et pour cela il ya une
cellule de coordination aérienne à trois
niveaux national zonal et
départementales qui sera désormais
systématiquement mise en oeuvre de
manière à ce qu'ils passent ce battement
de hockey pat heureusement si vous
préférez que je n'aime pas important
parce que on apparaît à la difficulté
parce que 1,1 des sapeurs pompiers
étaient en même temps pilote il a pris
la direction des opérations à la corde à
la tour de contrôle je crois de la
rochelle parce qu'il avait la double
casquette de pilote et puis de sapeurs
pompiers ce qui c'est qui fait que ça
s'est très bien passé
mais effectivement je pense que il faut
tirer les leçons de l'expérience pour
que ensuite on puisse avoir des réponses
immédiates et automatique sur les
réseaux de communication ils ont bien
fonctionné alors en clair le sdiss de
géantes maritime utilisent déjà le
réseau de communication antarès donc à
fonctionner très bien et ça parfaitement
pallié la saturation des lignes
téléphoniques ce soit les lignes fixes
ni portable le 10 de vendée fonctionne
encore comme vous savez sur un réseau
analogique mais le passage horizontale
c'est imminent et le réseau d'ailleurs
un âge il n'a pas connu de véritables
difficultés majeures pendant la crise
mais c'est vrai que l'évolution vers
antarès
constituera un progrès alors deuxième
aspect les demandes de reconnaissance de
catastrophe naturelle
je crois qu on peut dire que là aussi
les ces demandes ont été traitées dans
les délais beaucoup plus rapide qu'à
l'accoutumée on a battu tous les records
norman ont naturellement il ya des
demandes analogie ah oui et non massage
et évidemment ça donne de notamment ce
qui s'est déroulé il ya quelques jours
sur la façade méditerranéenne nous a
demandé aussi d'aller très vite on a
battu des records sur la vitesse et on
avait battu d'accord sur le périmètre
puisque l'ensemble des communes des
départements keith carr été mises en
alerte rouge ont été prises en compte
dans l'arrêté mois la pluie avec quatre
départements qui ont été déclarées en
état de catastrophe naturelle charente
maritime deux sèvres vendée vienne il
arrêté était pliée dès le 1er mars
ensuite les 62 communes de la gironde et
la loire atlantique et la c était le 12
mars étaient publiés et enfin 3 millions
de crédits soit millions d'euros crédit
d'extrême urgence ont été déléguées aux
préfets dont 1,6 ont été utilisés déjà
pour des secours personnalisé pour des
réquisitions d'entreprises locales pour
les travaux de première urgence
alors les collectivités dans les heures
qui ont suivi des catastrophes
naturellement les collectivités locales
ont rencontré de très nombreuses
difficultés on a essayé d'en doute la
mesure du possible de leur apporter des
réponses je parvenir ce que vous avez
auditionné le secrétaire d'état au
logement benoist apparu sur toutes les
questions des relogement des sinistrés
et du plan de reconstruction des digues
et je ne reviendrai pas sur le foot donc
la mobilisation du fonds barnier
vous êtes donc informés des solutions
envisagées qui sont à long terme
j'aimerais revenir simplement en
quelques mots sur les mesures d'urgence
que j'ai ordonné dans les heures qui ont
suivi la catastrophe
ça me permet d'ailleurs de rendre
hommage au préfet et à leurs services
qui ont relayé ces consignes alors
d'abord c'est le relogement d'urgence
des familles vous savez que je me suis
un athée rejet d'un fonds spécifique le
fond des de relogement d'urgence de fa
rue et qui permet d'apporter un
financement communes qui prennent en
charge soit le relogement d'urgence soit
la réalisation de travaux donc de les
aider et c'est ainsi que son délégué un
million et demi d'euros 1 million pour
la charente-maritime 500000 euros pour
la vendée ensuite nous avons prêté une
attention particulière pour toutes les
infrastructures fragilisées ou détruites
par la tempête
une mission d'inspection comme vous le
savez un technicien travaille
actuellement au recensement et à
l'évaluation des dommages et le pré
rapport doit être rendu dans les jours
qui viennent on sait à peu près en fin
de cette semaine ou de 27 semaines donc
senna les rapides en première
approximation
les préfets ont indiqué que les dégâts
constatés dans les quatre départements
s'élèverait à 117 millions d'euros pour
un taux de subvention de l'état qui
atteint 40 % et j'ai demandé et obtenu
d'ailleurs du ministre du budget que 25
millions d'euros soit d'ores et déjà
ouverts sur ce programme ça a été
confirmé comme vous savez là aussi la
semaine et elle lors du vote de la loi
de finances rectificative et je demande
vraiment à ce que j'ai demandé vraiment
préfet que ces sommes soient versés dans
les meilleurs délais j'ai incité
naturellement sur l'urgence de tout cela
j'ai aussi veiller à ce qu'un dossier
soit transmis au fonds de solidarité
l'union européenne ce n'est que lors de
la tempête klaus de 2009 la france avait
bénéficié de ce fonds et dans les
victimes de catastrophes naturelles de
grande ampleur une mission ministérielle
donc d'évaluation a été diligentée dans
les jeux
ont suivi la catastrophe vient de rendre
son rapport qui a été adressée à la
commission de bruxelles la semaine
dernière et la commission rendra sa
décision à la fin du mois de juin donc
on a un calendrier est connue donc on a
mis concrètement en fait tous les moyens
de notre côté mais il faut être aussi
lucide et il n'est pas tout à fait
certain que les dégâts constatés
convergent avec les critères retenus par
ce fonds notamment quant au périmètre
des zones dévastées
enfin on aura zéro alors de manière
dérogatoire
enfin j'ai sollicité et obtenu du midi
julie j'ai la possibilité d'un
remboursement en année n de la tva pour
les dépenses des collectivités
départements et communes concernées par
le périmètre catastrophes naturelles
cette dotation a été fixé la semaine
dernière à 30,2 millions d'euros à
l'occasion du vote non quand une fois du
collectif ça concerne également la
gironde la vienne les deux sèvres la
loire atlantique et le décret est en
continu tu revois suit un processus qui
est normal ceci étant dit je souhaite
que cette tempête xynthia soit
l'occasion de mener plusieurs réformes
structurelles et les phénomènes naturels
de ce type demeure bien évidemment
imprévisible mais on doit se présentent
une meilleure organisation encore doit
nous permettre de mieux nous prémunir de
ces conséquences je considère
globalement dh crois que c'est de
l'analyse départager des membres de la
mission d'autres missions que la
coordination entre les composants de la
gestion des risques prévisions
prévention protection peut être encore
amélioré et
les facteurs de la chanson naturel dans
vingt et les causes sont humaines et
donc ça signifie je les dis quand j'ai
une débuté mais je crois bien
profondément il faut que ça signifie
qu'il faut faire émerger une véritable
culture commune du risque et l'état dans
ce domaine bien évidemment à vocation à
assurer un rôle prééminent j'ai donc
saisi le ministre du budget de
l'économie de l'écologie du logement
pour réformer le système des
catastrophes naturelles afin de
renforcer la prévention est d'encourager
des comportements sur davantage
responsables j'ai donné des instructions
pour ce qui concerne celui de
l'intérieur que je vous résume d'abord
afin d'améliorer le système dallaire
d'informations météorologiques
il faut sans doute intégrer au système
d' alerte que nous connaissons et la
vigilance de submersion marine ce qui
n'est pas le cas comme vous savez à
l'heure actuelle puisque concrètement
les récentes avancées technologiques
permettent d'envisager une accélération
permettant d'aboutir en fait un nouveau
système d' alerte avant la fin 2011
et ce système ça paierait vagues
submersion qui nous permettrait
d'intégrer le phénomène couplé vents
violents et fortes vagues aux
dispositifs de vigilance qui n'était pas
le cas jusque là et d'identifier les
zones littorales les plus fragiles qui
nécessite une topographie très précises
sur le modèle de la fois sur des
tsunamis de ça dont on peut s'inspirer
et enfin une constitution d'une base de
connaissances du
intégrant des mesures de hauteur d'eau
jusque là aussi on sait qu'il ya eu des
cas retiennent insuffisant alors à côté
de ça je pense aussi aux plans communaux
de sauvegarde
ces plans comme savaient qu'ils
déterminent les mets des mesures
immédiates relève des compétences du
ministère l'intérieur je pense qu'il
faut un système dallaire et d'évacuation
qui se fonde sur les plans communaux de
sauvegarde car concrètement en réalité
une évacuation sa s'improvise pas et là
on a encore vu il faut ensuite dans de
la prévention liée les plans de
prévention des risques naturels aux
plans communaux de sauvegarde et imposé
ses plans de communauto garde dès lors
que l'on constate des risques et par
exemple on observe qu'en charente
maritime
sur les 21 communes soumises à
l'obligation de réaliser pcs une seule
elle avait effectivement réalisé
or celle ci dessous est différente en
vendée ce qui vous fera plaisir puisque
les plans prévention risques naturels
prescrits et n'ayant pas été approuvés
aucune commune avait réglementairement
le réglementairement pour nous cette
précaution l'obligation de réaliser un
plan communal de sauvegarde
alors pour remédier à cette incohérence
juridique et
et comme le délai entre la prescription
du plomb et son approbation peut excéder
deux ans je proposerai donc dans de
meilleurs délais une modification de la
législation actuelle pour un bpc
obligatoire dès la prescription du plan
de prévention qui est pas ce battement
j'ai donc demandé aux préfets
département par une circulaire du 6
avril de renforcer leurs efforts de
sensibilisation auprès des maires là je
pensais aussi c'est indispensable
deuxième remarque et je veux rappeler là
aussi avec beaucoup de force que j'ai
toujours préconisé un contrôle de
légalité resserré sur les conséquences à
mettre cette sécurité des personnes et
les questions du droit des sols et
d'urbanisme sont traités par le ministre
d'état et mais les préfets joue un rôle
majeur par naturellement dans ce domaine
et dans tout particulièrement dans
l'exercice du contrôle de légalité
je pense que les instructions ou les
moyens ne font absolument pas défaut
pour mener cette mission est pour ma
part je n'ai donné aucune instruction
que ce soit des instructions écrites ou
orales
nous pouvons laisser croire aux
représentants d'états que le contrôle de
légalité sur une activité secondaire ou
accessoires au contraire
depuis mon arrivée au lycée à
l'intérieur j'ai adressé au préfet deux
instructions donc écrite sur le contrôle
de légalité
le 23 juillet et le 1er septembre sinon
pas dans la période
nous évoquons cette instruction sur du
1er septembre
c'est une inspection détaillée précise
convainc page spécifiquement sur un
contrôle de légalité en matière
d'urbanisme et c'est cette instruction
rappelle le caractère prioritaire de
cette branche du contrôle
donc c'est encore une fois et
dans cette note dans cette instruction
il rappeler que le contrôle de
d'urbanisme des documents d'urbanisme et
des décisions individuelles seyant
claire des permis de construire
c'est présent ils sont postés comme des
axes priorités et enfin dans les jours
qui ont suivi
c'est un bête j'ai adressé au préfet
toujours avec le ministre d'état une
instruction de rappel et de ses outils
juridiques et d'ailleurs les ai
sollicités aussi pour l'accélération des
déploiements dpp voilà je voulais vous
dire brièvement et je crois que c'est
d'un des principaux engagements de cette
catastrophe et que l'état doit demeurer
au premier rang est des acteurs de
gestion de crise
donc moi j'ai fait de la sécurité son
sillage une priorité mon action et ça
s'applique par définition cette notion
sécurité à la gestion des risques en
général et aux conséquences de cette
catastrophe
plus particulièrement il va bien merci
monsieur le ministre alors on a quelques
quelques questions à vous poser d'abord
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que la
mission s'est exprimée l'autre jour on a
fait un premier point presse
partage cette idée que en france on a un
complexité une complexité de règles sans
doute extrêmes et c'est pas en rajoutant
des règles que on aura une meilleure
culture de la sécurité est en tout cas
du risque on a le sentiment que entre
les trois piliers prévisions prévention
et protection
ce qui manque c'est pas l'arsenal c'est
pas les outils pour chaque pilier ce qui
manque c'est qu'ils se parlent ce qui
est un peu plus de cohérence et ça je
pense que c'est quelque chose qu'on va
on va on va travailler dans les semaines
à venir
si je reprends les trolls et les trois
points le premier point sur sur la
prévision donc effectivement météo
france c'est prévoir les surcotes en mer
pour l'instant on n'arrive pas à prévoir
la console et conséquences de la surcote
sur le trait de côte
vous avez répondu avec un nouveau modèle
vagues submersions marines et ça je
pense que c'est quelque chose de
d'extrême importance à sera un bon outil
sur les plans communaux de sauvegarde
ont fait le même constat que vous nous
avions l'intention nous aussi de lier
par une disposition législative beaucoup
plus étroitement l'existence des ppr et
pérenne à l'existence des plans
communaux de sauvegarde donc je déduis
que vous iriez dans même sens vendent en
tout cas que ce serait validée par
d'accord donc ça c'est un point qui nous
semble important alors on a beaucoup de
deux communes qui sont des petites
communes je vois par exemple sur le
littoral a qui peuvent gonfler à
plusieurs disent fait un bruit des
milliers des milliers l'été mais qui
l'hiver c'était le cas notamment en
embauchant pajtim se retrouve un 1000
1500 2000 bon elles ont pas des services
suffisants pour pouvoir monter des
services notamment compétent pour monter
des plans communaux de sauvegarde est ce
que il vous apparaît que l'état pourrait
sur cet aspect quand même qu'il est
encore une fois le coeur du métier de
l'état de la sécurité notamment des
personnes est ce que l'état pourrait
apporter un soutien un appui pour que
les communes notamment les plus petites
d'entre elles puisse monter des plans
communaux de sauvegarde qui
correspondent à la hauteur des besoins
c'est important autant autant en pente
et est-ce qu'il faut que ces plans
communaux de sauvegarde reste au niveau
du périmètre communal ou est-ce qu'il
faut les remontées un périmètre
intercommunal a cédé points un peu
partout et y ait un sens chez moi très
positivement sur le principe du concours
de l'état aux communes pour
l'établissement des pcs ça j'y suis
totalement favorable donc l'arrêt
première pratique la réponse est non ce
oui positive deuxième élément sur le
périmètre communal ou intercommunal
ça existe on a un exemple
oui on en a un exemple plan
intercommunal sauvegarde qui est toulon
puisque l'agglomération de toulon et qui
fait donc onze communes l'agglomération
toulon depuis trois ans maintenant un
plan interne le sauveur l'idée inclut un
système dallaire des populations donc on
y est favorable
enfin je précise qu'à ce jour seuls
l'agglomération de toulon de toulon a
développé cette initiative et et si
j'ose dire pour cause puisque on a reçu
le maire adjoint tout à l'aps qui se
trouve ce chêne var est aussi président
de la fédération nationale de protection
civile et donc il nous a remis des
documents je pense que c'est très
intéressant je sais qu'il travaille en
étroite collaboration avec avec le
ministère donc ça je pense que c'est
quelque chose capitale
si les services peuvent nous faire si
votre cabinet peuvent nous faire
parvenir les éléments de chiffres
notamment entre le nombre de ppr qui
sont prescrits et le nombre de plans
communaux de sauvegarde pour que l'on
puisse avoir en parallèle les les deux
chiffres et qu'on puisse les comparer ça
chauffe france sera intéressant alors
sur sur les éléments maintenant de la
prévention d'urbanisme il ya trois
points de faiblesse qui nous sont
apparus au fur et à mesure de l'avancée
de nos études premier point de faiblesse
il semble que les préfets ont du mal à
déférer au tribunal admistratif les
actes individuels donc les permis de
construire on a un pourcentage de
déférer qui est proche de zéro il est de
0,0 24%
ça c'est un premier point de faiblesse
le deuxième point de faiblesse sur
l'urbanisme c'est que on constate que
pour 80 % des permis de construire
l'état les préfectures en fait sont
aussi bien services instructeurs et en
même temps exposé qu'ils assurent le
contrôle de légalité donc est ce que la
double casquette
peut-être un biais dans le dos contrôle
de légalité puisque l'état se trouve à
la fois en amont dans l'instruction et
en aval dans le contrôle de légalité
et puis troisième point de faiblesse
il nous semble que effectivement le
contrôle des legati l'égalité souvent se
fait par sondage un certain nombre
d'informations qui nous ont été remontés
font état d'un manque de moyens est ce
qu'il faudrait pas systématiser sur
contrôle de légalité
vous l'avez un peu dit d'ailleurs
systématiser le contrôle de légalité
pour la sécurité des personnes
quand il ya un ppr ya un risque grave et
donc on demande aux préfectures
pratiquement de systématiser le contrôle
de légalité sur ces périmètres là ils
peuvent pas tout faire ils peuvent pas
voir tous les actes qui leur sont
transmis mais au moins là parce qu'il
s'agit encore une fois de la
préoccupation majeure de l'état de la
sécurité des personnes on demande au
préfet à ce moment-là d'observer une
discipline extrêmement strictes sur sur
ces périmètres la et plusieurs points
d'abord il faut rappeler que jusqu'en
2000 et l'a vu nabéré réhabiliter du
littoral et aux submersions marines
étaient inconnues totalement inconnu et
en tout et ça pouvait donc pas
naturellement motivé que quelques
déferrement que ce soit le contrôle de
légalité
faut-il le rappeler s'exerce en fonction
des éléments à la disposition des
services de l'état au moment où est
prise la décision
c'est ça le principe jusqu'en 2000 il
n'y avait pas de données sur les risques
du mans sur marine du littoral ce qui
signifie donc que le contrôle de
légalité des autorisations d'urbanisme
portait en fait sur l'application des
dispositions de la loi littoral alors
les autorisations d'urbanisme qui ont
été livrés plus particulièrement c'est
ça des requins susciter la nation dans
la cuvette de la faute-sur-mer et non
pas été déféré au tribunal administratif
de nantes
parce que selon les critères de l'époque
les apparaissait légal l'explication
elle est là
en revanche des cas et écarte que
cartographier le risque de submersion
marine du littoral les préfets ont
adapté leur contrôle de légalité par
exemple dès 2001 le préfet de vendée
version est certainement à déférer au
téat de nantes une autorisation
d'aménager un parc résidentiel de
loisirs qui a été délivré par la commune
de pamiers d'afrique sur mer en janvier
c'est le thé à de nantes puis ensuite la
cour administrative d'appel de nantes
qui n'ont pas jugé
essentiel dauphin bon d'annuler cette
décision il ya une ça signifie que
jusqu'à la fin de 2004 on pouvait pas
sérieusement envisagé de déférer des
autorisations d'urbanisme au motif que
ça concernait les terrains exposés ou de
subventions marais une concrètement
alors il ya une évolution partir 2005
puisque les préfets à partir 2005 et ont
constaté une évolution de la
jurisprudence
dt ha où on intégrer cette notion de
risque de submersion marine
alors ça signifie que concrètement les
autorisations et qui étaient instruits
par la dde ont été strictement contrôlés
par rapport au projet de plan de
prévention du risque inondation de
l'estuaire de la rivière et c'est le
lait là c'est ça dont certaines
dispositions d'ailleurs ont fait l'objet
d'une application qui est une
application anticipée par un arrêté
préfectoral de juin 2007 depuis 2005
très concrètement il ya eu dix sept
autorisations d'urbanisme qui ont été
déférés par le préfet de
charente-maritime et 12 par le préfet
demande et ça donne une indication
quantitative alors ensuite vous me
disiez que la mission était frappé par
finalement 7 euros seront double des
préfectures
et chargé la fois d'instruire les
demandes permis de construire et de
contrôler a posteriori par les petites
communes bien sûr et de contrôler a
posteriori loin évidemment l'égalité
alors c'est vrai que deux dans la loi de
83 le législateur avait introduit le
principe de séparation de l'instruction
et du contrôle ce principe est appliqué
je vous dis très strictement par le
ministère de l'écologie je sais plus si
ça s'appelle exactement un bref à
l'environnement enfin développant dû en
voir une idée enfin bon on a compris le
meeddem donc voilà et donc ce ministère
veille à ce qu'un agent qui est en
charge de l'instruction d'appel
construire ne soit pas également
responsable de son contrôle ya une
distinction logique c'est mon ami
naturellement entre les deux alors en
vendée plus particulièrement
l'organisation qui a été adopté par la
préfecture et par les spécialistes la
préfecture repose très exactement sur le
respect de ces principes ce ne sont pas
les mêmes équipes et qui au sein des
services de l'état qui instruit c'est à
dire d'un côté les services spécialisés
de la dde et celles qui contrôlent la
légalité c'est la préfecture jusqu'en
2005 puis ensuite une équipe social
dédié
la dde dans lequel la chante maritime le
contrôle les dossiers qui font l'objet
de l'objet d'un avis divergent entre la
proposition du service instructeur
fantômes et la décision du maire ça fait
partie du programme prioritaire et
tabler pour 2011 il ya une distinction
c'est vrai entre vent de niveau de
l'exemption 12 mai et la charente
maritime
oui j'ai dit chante dans ses jambes à un
succès sur un ancien rapporteur vous
poser une question sur la sueur sur ce
même fait monsieur le ministre nous
avons été très impressionnés par les
propos remplis de franchise du préfet de
la vendée qui nous signalait que j'ai
cru je sais que tu comprends ces
différentes étapes territoriale peut pas
dire que la vie soit divergent d'accord
mais la franchise se maintient
apparemment pendant tout car toute la
carrière et cette franchise le
conduisait à dire mais franchement je ne
comprends pas pourquoi le contrôle de
qualité a été aussi faibles avant moi
si on reprend ses propos et donc lui
s'étonnait c'est à dire qu'il voyait
matière à des déférés qui n'ont pas été
exercés par par ses prédécesseurs il y a
en plus sans doute de décision de permis
de construire illégal
il y a aussi des habitations qui était
qui ont été construites sans permis de
construire
et la question qui s'est posée c'est
pourquoi ces maisons construites sans
permis n'ont pas fait l'objet après de
procédures judiciaires qui auraient pu
permettre des sanctions ça ses premiers
points 2 deuxième observation on a reçu
aussi l'autre jour quelqu'un sur cette
double casquette du nez services de la
préfecture qui évidemment reprenez votre
argumentation qui est tout à fait juste
en disant ce sont pas exactement les
mêmes personnes qui à la fois
instruisent et qui en même temps font
contrôle de légalité mais il faut ne
faisait cette observation plein de
psychologie en disant qu' il
la personne qui exerce un contrôle dès
l'été n'était pas tout à fait à l'aise
pour déférer un acte deux d'un de ses
collègues
donc moi je crois qu'avec les métiers à
réflexion pour savoir si on doit pas
distinguer mieux la fonction de contrôle
de la fonction d'instruction j'ai déjà
un peu répondu sur ce point dans mon
intervention je partage un peu votre
analyse
je rappelle simplement que la circulaire
que j'ai signé le 1er septembre qui
d'ailleurs est dans la continuité de sa
de et janvier 2006 a fixé les priorités
pour l'exercice du contrôle de légalité
en tenant compte d'air de la réforme des
autorisations d'urbanisme qui peut vous
savez à évoluer en 2007 en octobre 2007
et 7 circuler en rites et vise à
améliorer les possibilités de conseil
vous approchez on peut peut-être
demander plus simplement à la régie ces
circulaires donc deux visent à améliorer
en amont le conseil au préfet lorsqu'il
y à l'élaboration des documents
d'urbanisme parce que ça permet plus
conseil en amont des pointus précis
efficace et plus à la fin le contrôle
est allégé le contrôle final et surtout
considérablement allégées j'ai demandé
aussi au préfet est attaché une
importance particulière à l'impératif de
sécurité publics et ça effectivement il
faut sensibiliser dans ses démarches et
notamment sécurité publique précisément
au travers à l'occasion des décès et
risques naturels et technologiques
donc
et enfin troisièmement ce que je vous ai
indiqué tout à l'heure il ya cette
circulaire de septembre 2009 et rappelle
très clairement quand je suis avait
vingt pages rappelle que le contrôle de
finalement de l'égalité sous l'angle de
la sic de la sécurité c'est une priorité
il n'y a aucune ambiguïté de la part d
instruction adressée au représentant de
l'état
je reprends juste l'un des éléments que
leur apportent leur soulignait c'est sûr
qu'une d'aiguillon on a eu non seulement
de nombreuses maisons qui ont été
érigées sens en famille construire mais
sur le domaine public maritime de l'état
et j'ai constaté qu' il y avait une
prescription qui était seulement que
trois ans hier qu'il y avait une sorte
de droit acquis au bout du bout de trois
ans et je trouve que une prescription de
trois ans quand on récupère je dire
quand tu fais une maison sans construire
sur un terrain de l'état sur domaine
public franchement je trouve que la
règle elle est quand même bien souple et
elle est quand même bien favorable moi
il me semble que je pense ce sera une
des propositions de cons qu'on pourra
faire mais il me semble qu'une
prescription beaucoup plus lointaine
ça permettrait de donner un signal très
clair que le retour du bâton il peut
venir
vient après trois ans parce que sinon
c'est quand même une prime à la triche
et j'ose dire si on passe le sont pas
sous le radar pendant trois ans le droit
le droit est acquis ou peut-être pour
être précis et vous donner la somme des
référés se donne un avis de grand deux
là 11 donc pour la charente-maritime
sion fait le total fait 34 et pour la
vendée ça ferait 24 sommes des référés
pour les deux départements sur pour
répondre à cette notion triennal avant
que vous évoquez et la construction sur
le domaine public
et concrètement imprescriptibles et il
ya le problème de droits acquis dans ce
domaine
parce que là c'est d'accord à ce que
l'on nous a lot to ont posé la question
entre jour nous a donné trois ans de de
prescription il jouait pas dans quel
cadre
c'est au dehors du domaine public voilà
et dans le domaine public c'est
impressionnant et privé d'accords un
sujet qui peut très sensible du sous
certains angles et ailleurs ouais j'ai
parlé je vous inviterai ailleurs plus
dessus de moi là par exemple beaucoup
plus au sud
je vois bien jouer bien sûr domaine
public c'est complètement alors aux
hôtes dernier point sur sur l'urbanisme
ce que ce que les préfets nous font nous
ont remonté aussi comme indication
c'est que la rgpp a désigné comme niveau
privilégié de déconcentration de l'état
le niveau régional ce qui fait que il ya
pas mal de ressources humaines de l'état
qui sont passés du niveau départemental
au niveau régional ce faisant est ce que
vous estimez que les préfets les
préfectures honte aujourd'hui les moyens
les ressources humaines pour faire face
notamment si on considère que la
priorité c'est d'abord la sécurité
notamment des personnes pour faire face
au contrôle de légalité mais bref à tout
ce qui peut aller dans le sens d'une
garantie de la sécurité de nos
concitoyens
et alors même que le personnel
départemental notamment les préfets
supporte toujours la responsabilité
c'est à dire que ils ont la
responsabilité
à la suite d'une erreur et cetera ils
peuvent avoir une aux mêmes
responsabilités pénales et pour autant
le sentiment qu'on en a c'est que l'air
gpp la régionalisation de l'état leur
enlève des moyens qui leur permet pas
d'assumer la pleine et entière
responsabilité
démission
qui leur sont dévolues
la répartition préfet de région préfet
département ce un sujet naturellement
évolutif et j'ai l'occasion d'ailleurs
de préciser les choses
la vérité souligne par exemple si le
rapporteur quand je suis arrivé
vomissant de l'intérieur j'avais été
auparavant ministre délégué aux
collectivités territoriales et à
l'époque je crois que j'avais déjà écrit
d'ailleurs dans un lit mais en tout cas
je le pensais j'étais assez favorable à
ce qui est finalement une autorité
hiérarchique préfet de région préfet
département avec tout ce que ça implique
j'ai changé d'avis depuis ma prise de
fonctions parce que concrètement que ce
qu'est ce que cela signifierait
notamment pour les élus ça signifierait
que le préfet de région devenait une
instance d'appel des décisions du préfet
département et donc j'ai évolué sur ce
dispositif
encore une fois je pense que je me suis
je me suis contredit parce que je me
suis quasiment sûre d'avoir écrit cela
dans les années 2000
4 et finalement à usage je pense qu'il
faut être assez prudent dans un van
hamme même si le rôle du préfet de
région et elle doit être naturellement
conforter donc ça signifie pour répondre
exactement à notre marque que le
contrôle de légalité est une compétence
du préfet du département et on a aussi
gelé rappelé dans cette circulaire de
septembre et et c'est une prérogative
qui est constitutionnel en fait
supportive constitutionnelle du préfet
de département et donc pour le dessus
des choses sont claires mais même si
c'est vrai qu'il peut y avoir une
ambiguïté notamment dans l'esprit les
interlocuteurs que coûte et
collectivités avec un essai de
compétence du me fais département et on
voit si vous voulez vous indiquer
clairement que la priorité de l'état ça
doit être la garantie de la sécurité des
personnes
on voit bien quand il ya une catastrophe
et d'ailleurs c'est l'occasion pour nous
je crois de rendre hommage aux au préfet
qui est un chant patiner et en vendée
guy là-dessus ont eu un comportement
absolument remarquable mais on voit bien
que le niveau de l'état qu'est le niveau
proche et le niveau efficace c'est
niveau départemental donc ça je crois
qu'il ya du point de vue de
l'organisation de l'état à des
concentrations des leçons à tirer de ces
expériences là je vais passer maintenant
à l'indemnisation des collectivités les
collectes alors il ya plusieurs
mécanismes qui qui existe notamment un
mécanisme autour de la des calamités
fallait catastrophe naturelle donc vous
en avait parlé il a été activé
pas de souci il ya un deuxième mécanisme
que votre ministère gère qui est une
subvention d'équipement aux
collectivités pour les biens non
assurables et ça permet si vous voulez
de fermer l'angle mort du premier
dispositif est ce que vous est-ce que
vous envisagez de l'activer dans quelles
conditions comment pour que les
collectivités qui avait quand même
beaucoup de bien à pilsen assurables qui
ont été très endommagées puisse
retrouver à peu près un niveau de
compensation qui leur permettent de
réinvestir
bon et
comme vous l'avez rappelé les biens non
assurables des collectivités
territoriales ont été concrètement très
endommagée très gravement endommagé et
par par la tempête et particulièrement
dans le département de la charente
maritime vendée gironde et loire
atlantique le cas ce que l'on retrouve à
chaque à chaque état alors compte tenu
de la gravité
je crois que c'était le président qui
l'avait annoncé sur place mais on a
diligenté une mission d'inspection
inter-ministérielle par lettre du 2 mars
est donc cette le pré rapport doit être
rendu quinze jours lady dans cette
semaine et le rapport définitif sera
donc connu pour la fin de ce mois alors
les dégâts concernent notamment la
voirie communale et départementale
concerne les ponts et des ouvrages d'art
ordina tual ans que ça fait l'objet d'un
financement qui la finance en
particulier les réseaux d'assainissement
et d'eau potable les stations
d'épuration et de ravages des eaux ainsi
que certains d'autres travaux l'occasion
paraît taillé le montant des travaux
estimé par chacune des préfectures
concernées je vous rappel s'élève à 69
millions pour un charente-maritime 30
millions pour la bande et 13 millions
pour la gironde 5 millions pour leur
authentique c'est à dire donc un total
de 117 millions là aussi dans le
dispositif a été mise en place de deux
de réparation des dégâts et causé par la
calamité publique a été mise en place et
25 millions d'euros c'était un taux
moyen de subventions si je crois qu'en
possibilité d'autres 40% et ont été
ouverts en autorisations d'engagement à
ce stade 5 millions d'euros en crédits
de paiement
la décision a donc été validé par
cognitive gt1 la semaine dernière et les
enveloppes sur les partitions des
critères team et notamment l'urgence et
l'importance de la population à
desservir notamment s'agissant des
réseaux donc voilà à peu près on en est
sûr
que ce genre de discussion législative
se sucrer les subventions d'équipement
est ce que on enrichit donc vous ferez
suit donc vous aurez vite
d'accord d'accord alors il ya un autre
sujet consécutif aux fameuses zones
d'acquisition amiable notamment pour les
collectivités
on va avoir des collectivités alors que
les permis de construire ont été la
plupart du temps des livres et
légalement
on va avoir des collectivités qui vont
avoir une destruction de leurs bases
fiscales façon importante certaines
communes ça peut atteindre pratiquement
le tiers une base fiscale et la mission
réfléchi un mécanisme de compensation
qu'on pourrait peut-être appuyé sur le
parallèle avec au moment de la tp v7 est
reprise avec la contribution nouvelle
contribution économique ou quand une
commune perdait une entreprise qui fait
faillite voilà il y avait un fait il y
avait un mécanisme de lissage sur
plusieurs années qui permettait à la
commune d'avoir eu une partie sur un
fonds de péréquation nationale une
partie de compensation là on va avoir
encore une fois des communes où la th
la taxe d'habitation le foncier bâti
sera détruit pour pour toujours puisque
il s'agit plus d'installer des maisons
est ce qu'on peut imaginer une
compensation du même type qui existaient
pour les entreprises pour dédommager
partiellement et en le lit sans les
collectivités concernées alors
ce que vous n'avez pas précisé c'est que
total des pertes pourrait susciter aux
alentours d'un million huit cent mille
euros
absolument c'est un problème à
l'évidence un que que vous jouez la
réponse n'est pas n'est pas facile les
communes frappées par la tempête et dont
une partie du pâtis va devoir détruire
naturellement ça entraînera une perte
logique et consécutive et de de recettes
le système finalement si je comprends
bien un système que vous préconisez et
consiste à mettre en place un système de
compensation de perte de base un peu à
l'image de ce qui existe pour les tp
mais ça n'existe pas pour l'instant
faire de taxe foncière ou d'habitation
et là je peux pas m'avancer d'un réseau
de là ça suppose une concertation
interministérielle avec le ministère du
budget et puis en tout état de cause je
vois un dispositions législatives mais
je peux pas aller plus loin
enfin c'est un système lui aussi ont
proposé n'existe pas à l'heure actuelle
tout cas ce que ce que je simplement
souza par an mais voilà ce que je veux
simplement souligner c'est le parallèle
ce que je veux souligner aussi c'est que
il faudrait pas que le contribuable
local qui a été souvent d'ailleurs
sinistre m6 se retrouve avec une forme
de double peine c'est à dire que après
la destruction de la base fiscale
il soit encore plus imposée par la suite
pour que la commune puisse garder un
budget à peu près identique mais ce que
je peux vous indiquer à ce stade je ne
peux pas donner à sa sentiment de pas de
réponse c'est que j'appelerai la
démarche accord oui moi si vous
commettez choix revenir sur sur quelques
points et je vous poser trois questions
qui n'ont pas forcément de lien mais
autant le faire en même temps
la première question sur l'élaboration
des dppr et notamment des ppr et
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de date butoir
si bien que l'on peut se trouver dans
certains cas où au bout de neuf ans il
est toujours pas apte à l'adoption de
ppr est une des réflexions qui a été la
nôtre et sur lequel il faudrait que nous
allions à finaliser était de dire
pourquoi dans ce cas là au bout d'un
certain temps mettons trois ans si le
ppr n'a pas été adopté alors l'état on
transfère la compétence sa dette à
l'état
après avoir mis enfin c'est l'état qui a
seront là adopterait le pp est bon donc
ici ferait un peu la une la fin la
récréation si vous me permettez
l'expression deuxième
deuxième question on a été très marquée
par des problèmes de d'alert à la fois
avec une collecte de des informations
permettant d'alerter notamment les mères
qui a de multiples sources
il ya aussi bien l'ifremer aussi bien
météo france je sais que dans 2 ans voit
sa passe peut être par exemple et les
ports tout ça est une masse d' alerte
qui ne donne pas lieu à une fusion le
préfet n'est pas toujours informés de la
totalité de ces éléments et le préfet
ensuite après va dire au maire que il ya
une alerte etc mais ce qui nous revient
c'est que les mères parfois sont
désorientés par le nombre d' alerte ils
disent finalement on en soit si souvent
qu'au fond
l ol perdre de la crédibilité comment
faire pour assurer une meilleure chaîne
d'information et qu'à un moment donné le
préfet prenne la responsabilité de dire
au maire là dans ce cas là il ya une
alerte qui va nécessiter une évacuation
de la population parce qu'à l'évidence
évidemment le maire ne sais pas s'il
faut évacuer ou pas la population
troisième point qui était un peu de
nature différente et tu concerne un peu
la gironde
dans certains cas il n'y a pas de zones
noires nous avons la chance de ne pas
avoir des zones noires
pour autant il ya des habitations qui
ont été submergées et des gens qui
seront trouvées sur le toit de leur
maison
et aujourd'hui ces gens nous disent nous
on n'a été exposée voilà la preuve est
rapportée et on ne peut pas obtenir une
cession amiable de notre maison
alors est-ce qu'il faut attendre que i
les prochaines tempêtes et que cette
fois ci elle soit en zone noire ou est
ce qu'on ne peut pas étendre la
procédure de l'acquisition amiable aussi
à des biens qui sont exposés à ce type
de sinistre
bien et
premier point sur la date butoir pour
moi la date butoir je pense qu'elle est
souhaitable mais sur ce plan a eu une
réponse hier à l'assemblée puisque dans
le cadre du grenelle 2 ça a été écartée
mais je partage assez votre votre
analyse la tuer votre sentiment sur ce
point bon voilà on verra après comment
tout ça évolue mais enfin en tout cas de
l'assemblée s'est prononcée contre et
l'alertent deuxième interrogation de la
leyre pour la merde comme vous savez et
c'est de la compétence du maire c'est
son pouvoir de police
l'interlocuteur du maire battu avant
c'est le préfet
en matière d' alerte enfin là aussi vous
que les choses soient rappelé très très
très simplement et votre troisième point
de votre troisième c'était évolution
c'est en dehors des zones noires
pourquoi pas veillé sur amiable pour les
biens exposés là c'est pas de ma
compétence assez la compétence pas
m'avancer plus avancée la compétence
pour le coup du ministère des mines m
et est ce que ce nice parce que les
leurs en fait ce qui met rappelait
d'ailleurs à juste titre c'est que les
propriétaires qui ne sont pas au doigt
bas il n'y a pas eu d'indemnité à sion
parce que les experts ont considéré que
le danger n'était pas mortelle pour
parler clair c'est la réalité sur votre
toit vous dites je suis beaucoup de
chance d'être encore sur le toit
en réalité les les zones ont été
prescrit uniquement pour les
départements les deux départements qui
ont fait l'objet de la tempête c'est la
raison pour laquelle il n'y a pas eu de
rival à 11 juste pour pour terminer
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment parce
que bon ça a été évoqué un certain
nombre de deux fois est ce que vous avez
le sentiment que dans ce qui s'est passé
le principe de la décentralisation et
été remise en cause ou le partage la
décentralisation est ce que le curseur
entre élus et contrôle de l'état préfet
et est à la bonne place
est ce que il ya un élément comment
dirais-je la démocratie locale qui a été
défaillant est ce que est ce que donne
parce qu'on a on a vu des appréciations
qui ont été portées parfois dures
parfois avec une tentative de désigner
tel ou tel bouc émissaire est-ce que la
décentralisation qui est une liberté
qu'on accorde
des élus locaux mais qui à la
contrepartie de la responsabilité aussi
est-ce que ça booste ça vous semble
cette décentralisation avoir été remise
en cause
au cours de ce processus ou pas du tout
non je pense que comme vous j'ai été
attentif des sessions toutes les
déclarations nombreuses et riches qui se
se sont produits tous les requins
s'étant exprimé sur ces sujets au mans
des lois de décentralisation le faire un
choix c'est le transfert a été de
pouvoir d'urbanisme on perd la question
pourrait se poser
moi je me souviens j'étais très jeune
mais comme je suis assez vieux
maintenant j'étais pas si jeune que ça
mais je me suis très bien dans les
années 80 82 il y avait un certain
nombre de maires
la branche zones urbaines et
semi-urbaines et qui n'était pas très
enthousiaste la dévolution des pouvoirs
d'urbanisme pour une raison simple c'est
comment résister à la pression d'une
famille d'une notoriété en quelque sorte
locales parfois et qui avait donc signé
d'en imposer dans des conventions avec
les préfectures pour l'étudier pour le
l'étude des cas d'un certain nombre de
cas je vous dire très précis ça allait
de la famille on paraît clair la famille
nombreuse qui pouvait jouer un rôle
comme ça ou d'une commune qui
accueillait des personnalités sur le
littoral ça peut se produire par exemple
c'est donc et
donc on se souvient de ce qu'elle a
mangé entendu aussi des remarques de
responsables de rendre collectivités ni
quand pourquoi ne pas transférer la
compétence finalement au département
enfin au conseil général plus exactement
au conseil général
ceux qui auraient la garantie à la fois
du recul de l'autorité
d'avoir un interlocuteur un peu d'égal à
égal avec le représentant de l'état un
dialogue d'égal à égal
moi je pense qu'il n'y a pas eu de
remise en cause des principes
décentralisation chacun à ses
responsabilités le maire point la
décision et le préfet contrôle je pense
pas qu'ils aient droit mise en cause
même si encore une fois c'est la ouvert
des réflexions petit bon je dis cela
très honnêtement parce que je suis
m'auditionner c'est une expression
publique au sénat dans un cadre plus
privé où je pourrais aller un peu plus
loin mais mais à ce stade comme in the
l'intérieur je sais bien comprendre que
vous retenez dans quel sens justement je
n'aime pas le sens bon va très bien bien
écoutez je tournais à porter pour savoir
s'ils avaient des questions
complémentaires dont va coûter merci
monsieur ministre merci merci de nous
communiquer les éléments peut-être deux
chiffres qu'on a demandé sur les plans
communaux de sauvegarde notamment que
l'épée périt pour qu'on puisse les
mettre en en parallèle merci c'est la
fin de cette audition pour la revoir
notre site internet publicsenat.fr je
vous donne rendez vous à 16h30 pour le
début de l'examen du projet de loi de
modernisation de l'agriculture
bonne journée à tous sur public sénat